at my age now I really believe it's not
I'm breaking down 46 no that's not
that's fine
what that's fine I understand about that
but I don't live well okay I mean
there's some healthy snacks well we got
a joke about brittle we have toffee
brittle I hate these dried mangoes these
full of sugar let me ask you something
about Lacroix I don't know are the
sponsors no all of a sudden yeah for
sure
it is it is a zero calorie it's the
flavouring but it's still not
necessarily great for you because of the
carbonation right for your teeth in
particular what is that what does it do
with your carpet now here's a new
paranoia I know it is [ __ ]
carbonation dude your teeth it it erodes
the enamel and yeah if you if you are
constantly doing it if you you know they
had those videos online you can see if
you leave a tooth tell him oh dear he
has four enamels a total maintain and
the rest are just raw nerves just like
whale teeth look like lean it's like
little straw there are just certain
things I've learned over time you can't
you meet with gums you can give a damn
takes a while yeah it hurts but you guys
just feel better too
maybe yeah but you know back in the day
when you'd see like all those people go
to uni God you've got guns you know yeah
oh you look at my hit look fine right
you good you like my teeth right you
look the same as when we met and I think
it you look exactly the same
you look more of a man yeah it was
boyish back then I was very young you
know but all the teeth that you see are
the ones that exist
the back there's no okay yeah there's no
back okay because I don't floss yeah
yeah I brush but once a day okay
and I didn't go to dentist for like 15
years right but you go now yeah so do
you have super teeth nothing you're not
you just goes what if they could put
just one giant molar yeah there you know
instead of putting multiple molars or
like a Bond villain to chopper that's
got like two giant metal like c4 ones to
be like gigantic - yeah back there yeah
that's a great idea do what would I have
to suggest it to them
they already have it they do that
sometimes when they don't they don't put
the proper tooth in the right place when
they implant the teeth because they
don't want to create gaps where things
can get in between sure so the cosmetic
dentists will usually say hey we'll put
a bigger one here just so there aren't
any gaps between your teeth oh so you
can tell them instead of making a molar
make a giant molar that's dope whoa or
like have like just one long curved like
exactly like a mouth guard yeah just one
giant one yeah like the grills like mask
teeth like Jim Carrey's the masks yeah
yeah yeah that's what I want that that's
what I want
but do they is that the type where they
shaved down the tooth and then they put
it on top and they drill it in and they
have to like do they drill those veneers
when they shave it down to like one of
those stupid ears all the way to the
battery your front teeth are fine those
are actually those have to be implanted
know what you did you shave down the
front teeth right then you put the
veneers on tougher but make the whole
thing truly inquire for you contact a
dentist let's ask that
[Music]